I did see Noah back last night oh yeah
yeah we're at speaking of sway yeah at
the at the old Drake show oh yeah I went
as well yeah yeah yeah for those that
did for those that don't know Alina and
I went to see Drake
and then Corbin Dallas over here went
and saw Drake and what were your
conclusions
well
you know I realized in many parts of the
show like oh he's not talking to me
right now he's not performing for me
right yeah right when I walked into the
Arena filled with
98 women I kind of took a look around
and said oh
I'm not the target demo I think that I
think the only part that really was
targeted towards us was the giant sperm
floating above the stage yeah you know
yeah that was for the dudes that was a
good meme yeah you know what I mean yeah
but then it was just like swimming
around and God yeah God you know come
I don't know if that was for us I think
it was for us I think it was aimed at
the boys yeah I think it was like fellas
right I'm just picking we all got this
in our nuts right I'm just picturing a
bunch of women screaming in the front
run he's like performing for them and
then Drake just kind of looks up to like
four Dudes in another section like oh
[Music]
yeah
there's a giant seam in there there's a
bunch like Siemens like swimming on the
stage too yeah like right below him it's
like what and then there's like there's
other parts where there's a laser that
projects vaginas onto the stage oh I
didn't see that yeah uh I don't wanna
you know
I don't flex but
Andre Iguodala former Golden State
Warrior was in front of us the whole
night was he really yeah that's kind of
cool you showed up kind of late it was
really it was really funny though
um
the parts that were very much like
for the ladies
that you could see the dudes in our
general vicinity just looking around and
taking a seat
um and it's like well yeah I don't know
if this is yeah our part of the show and
then there was a point where Andre was
on his phone looking at just basketball
clips
of himself no no just like other players
okay he's just on Instagram just like
looking at hoopers that's awesome and
then there was a part where he was
checking out the weather and I hate to
out him like this but yeah but it was
just you're kind of exposing him a
little bit Yeah and and granted I'm I'm
trying not to exaggerate these are just
glancing moments right like because our
seats were stacked now he's looking at
the weather for an hour
oh that's the funniest part to me was uh
they had that Jumbotron and they were
filming different parts of the crowd
yeah yeah with the filter on oh no oh
there's that part yeah that part was
funny I was dying at that part they had
like the crying Snapchat like the oh
they didn't do that so funny just random
people and they would and I was like why
is everyone crying it sounds like it's a
filter dude and I'm like oh right but
they'd show somebody on the Jumbotron
and they'd be like into the camera and
then they look up the thing
yeah
so funny no I just thought it was really
really funny and really cruel how they
would just cut to a white kid on the
n-word
yeah so many white kids being like
laughs
I'm like dang uh dude LeBron walked him
down oh which is pretty cool yeah and
his son did he do the thing where he
like walks down the stairs onto the
stage that [__] oh my God I was just
laughing yeah all the women he walked by
just fainting I know he kissed a
pregnant lady's stomach yeah
that's good I know that's good
oh
they're in the car that night she's like
we're naming him Drake
the husband's like what the [__] no
we're naming him after me we have to
it's decided yeah he decided it oh [__]
so rude he knows what he did in that
moment holy [__] bro yeah that's pretty
that's pretty like disrespectful I feel
like so crazy
we're naming him Aubry
his name is Aubry God bro
how did that happen did she legit like
was she wearing a short top and her
stomach was poking out yeah okay so
she's out yeah I for some reason
pictured him just like I'm butting like
unbuttoning a t-shirt
yeah like he like doubles back he passes
her and then like looks comes back feels
her stomach yeah he's like how many how
many months
how many months
six okay
second trimester okay yeah yeah and then
he then he lays down the kiss
then he gets on stage he's like
this lady right here is pregnant
she says she's six months
if I just kisses stomach I think we just
started over because I gave her
something new in there and then DJ and
then the song comes on maybe you might
think she's like
her husband just next to her
worst show ever show sucks she just
sucks ass that's why we're mad yeah yeah
that's why we're mad
stupid man it's not it's [__] whack
it's lame this is the best show I've
ever seen the whole time I was stressed
because like we're in a box and the
people that were there were like just
smoking weed yeah like the whole time
I'm like my pregnant wife is sitting
here I'm getting contact high right now
hahaha
Cody came to the Drake show not turned
on anime girls floating around stages
what is happening what is going on
[Laughter]
well he kissed that lady's stomach he's
gonna kiss my wife's stomach is that
part of the show can you sign up for
that
Drake my wife's pregnant yeah you go
crazy you see that on the Jumbotron
you're like oh this show rules sir
[Laughter]
damn show your stomach show your stomach
show him you're pregnant
what would you do if Drake just hooked
himself up to a stunt harness he's like
hey yo
float it up to your box just all of a
sudden it's like yes with the sperm in
the picture coming up here yes behind
him
he's just like a [__] Michelangelo
yeah yeah
Michelangelo kiss your [__] pregnant
wife's stomach
the shirt
[Music]
expose the belly oh my goodness yeah
yeah no we're just old yeah that's
really all it is I am old honestly
yeah my takeaway to the Drake concert
were this dude has a [__] ton of Music
he's very hype on stage
and I don't think this whole show was
for me yeah yeah that's fair I have the
same conclusions
but but I would all I actually I keep
saying it's lit I don't even think it's
really a gender thing because male Drake
fans
locked in yeah locked the [__] oh yeah
yeah they're singing our box that we're
filming themselves the entire yeah yeah
dude that part's crazy shy lens
yeah camera turned to them yeah singing
every lyric yeah they filmed the whole
thing that's Drake's energy he could
make what are they gonna do with that
bro Drake's energy makes uh otherwise
unassuming male turn into like a bad
[__]
got a grown man at his shows with the
with the flashlights on them being like
baby you my anything
I was like whoa so true yeah yeah
that [__] is crazy yeah
yeah and then um
you gotta love you gotta appreciate the
guys on and the standing like in front
of the stage you know the the
innocuous groups of two and three males
that you know they're probably early 20s
the social confidence really isn't there
and they're just looking around at all
the girls yeah they keep like loving
each other being like bro
be cool
you know what's really funny to me too
is that square stage yeah you're
standing on the floor
you know you're just like waiting
it's like watching like a horse race or
something
like you can't see him you hear him
rapping and you just know he's on the
other side of that Cube oh yeah yeah
there's TVs on the side of the stage
watching the projection but it was
really funny is the people just looking
up being like please please and then he
comes over for three seconds you see
like an inch of it yeah kind of like
lean over it and like go back the other
way oh
[Laughter]
just braids
there's one drop of sweat
yeah